foreign
[Music]
on Monday even the hens don't lay eggs
you find what you look for
actions speak louder than words
[Music]
a steady step is better than a run that
tires
he who runs with Wolves will learn to
howl
no matter how early you get up you can't
make the sun rise any sooner
[Music]
the closer you are to the tree the
better the shade
a dog that never goes out does not find
a bone
[Music]
a dog that barks does not bite
foreign
t with gloves doesn't catch mice
he who gets angry loses
[Music]
with warning there is no deception
better alone than poorly accompanied
[Music]
he who does not live to serve does not
deserve to live
the more invited the more festive the
party
every Chapel has its own celebration
he who disturbs the least helps the most
no flies into a closed mouth
the fishing is good in Stormy Weather
we are as small as our joy as big as our
pain
foreign
looks for their own onion to cry on
[Music]
full stomach happy heart
fewer donkeys more corn
[Music]
the road to hell is strewn with roses
never ask God to give you anything ask
him to put you where things are
[Music]
we are all made of the same clay but not
from the same mold
[Music]
who assists everybody assists nobody
one timely shout is better than constant
talk
[Music]
everyone makes firewood of a fallen tree
necessity is a great teacher
foreign
speak plainly call bread bread and wine
wine
tell me what you want to buy and I will
tell you what you are
[Music]
where there are weapons there will be
Wars
[Music]
if you give away what you have you will
not yearn for what you see
[Music]
though a cage may be made of gold it is
still a cage
thank you
it's not the fault of the mouse but of
the one who offers him the cheese
[Music]
a person born to be a flower pot will
not go beyond the porch
an ant on the Move does more than a
dozing Ox
[Music]
hunger brings people down Pride helps
them get up
[Music]
we were born to die
if you're a good musician one string is
enough
no fate is worse than a life without
love
[Music]
nobody leaves this world alive
he who lingers will hear bad things
spoken about him
[Music]
God is bigger than your problems
the Air's tears are but a mask to
disguise his Joy
who is accustomed to evil is offended by
good
he who strikes first strikes twice
since excuses were invented no one is
ever in the wrong
never confuse gratitude with love
a good rooster will Crow even on a dung
Heap
if you're hungry there is no hard bread
[Music]
your hometown is like a small Fatherland
house does not rest upon the ground but
upon a woman
[Music]
those who rescue are always crucified
you cannot worship an unknown saint
even the Saints patience has its limits
trust your best friend as you would your
worst enemy
if you want to live in peace you must
not tell everything that you know or
judge everything that you see
[Music]
he who speaks too much is tiresome he
who speaks too little is boring
[Music]
it's not enough to know how to ride you
must also know how to fall
if it is not stolen it is a legacy
[Music]
let the water you cannot drink Flow by
the right time to dine is for the rich
man when he is hungry for the poor when
he has something to eat
[Music]
if you don't honor your wife you are
dishonoring yourself
thank you
love is too rare to be lost on jealousy
[Music]
for every dog there is an appropriate
stick
[Music]
cleanliness is the luxury of the poor
Fortune is like a wall that falls on
those who lean on it
[Music]
the rat who only has one hole will soon
be caught by the cat
[Music]
marriage is the only war in which you
sleep with the Enemy
who knows nothing neither doubts nor
fears anything
he who follows his own advice must
accept the consequences
put a good face on the bad times
God helps the one who Rises early
the shrimp that falls asleep is Swept
Away by the current
oh
with money even the dog dances
when the river makes noise it's carrying
water
he who wants to hold everything holds
nothing
[Music]
he who leaves for the Villa loses his
chair
there is more time than life
[Music]
a bad weed Never Dies
a bird in the hand is worth more than a
hundred in Flight
[Music]
if you search you will find
the envious never give praise they only
accept it
[Music]
if you see a person who is silent and
avoids people stay away from him he has
been granted wisdom
one only visits the cactus when it bears
fruit
[Music]
judge others as you would be judged
when two poppers get married it is the
beginning of a generation of beggars
there is a time and a place for
everything
the devil knows more because he is old
not because he is the devil
foreign
if you abandon the one that you bear
lover of a student does not always
become the wife of a graduate
little by little one goes far
thank you for watching which quote did
you like best let us know in the
comments